Gene you made this statement that Eddie
Van Halen had had it with Van Halen and
he wanted to join kiss that's true and
Paul goes Gene that's not true that
never happened Howard what I said was I
saw Eddie in the studio and I spent time
with Eddie I was not privy to any of
that conversation the bottom line is
that Eddie called me out of the blue and
Gene I got to come down and see you I'm
having a miserable time and all that so
I said come on down can we go to lunch
and everything yeah there's a place
right across the street let's just go in
there and we're sitting having lunch
before we started in the studio at one
or two o'clock and he said I want to
join kiss wow you're not serious yeah
yeah yeah yeah I can't take Roth he's
driving me nuts and all this stuff and
basically the conversation was you're
out of your mind you got to rough it out
every band's got you know the ups and
downs you're it's called Van Halen it's
your band you got to stick it out and
all that stuff and then we came into the
studio and he played us I remember this
the for the demo or whatever of jump
that they were doing just with
synthesizers and we were looking at each
other going so you're going to add
guitars you're the greatest guitar
player what are you doing on the
keyboards yeah he goes no that's it
that's the whole song is it true that
Richie Sambora of Bon Jovi and Slash of
Guns and Roses auditioned to replace a
slash called me on the phone this this
really nice kid in high school named
Saul Hudson called me and he told me
that his mom had been uh seamstress or
something for Bowie and uh he sounded
terrific just a I I felt very taken with
him because he was very down to earth
and and very well spoken and he said my
friends call me slash and I thought that
was cute you know he's in high school
and he's called slash and I said you
know you're you're a little too young
for this but you know keep at it so um
he's done okay
Richie did try out for the band of
course she's always been a phenomenal
guitar player just didn't work within
the band again it worked out great for
for all of us
oh